contesta clothes needs of its remembers
that Porsche ruled out a plug-in hybrid
Panamera some time ago but this one is a
completely new and unique model called
the Panamera Turbo S e-hybrid sports re
smooth and it packs the power to go with
the name a whopping 680 horsepower that
opens up entirely new possibilities
MacLeish the sport Turismo wears the
same dynamic proportions and elegant
design elements as the Panamera sports
limousine the new Porsche is five and a
half meters long 1.4 meters tall and 1.9
meters wide
[Music]
the roof spoiler muscular sports car
Beltline and performance exhaust system
with two sets of twin tailpipes to find
the rear integrated into a horizontal
strip are the Porsche logo and LED
taillights the roof spoiler cuts air
resistance and fuel consumption at
speeds up to 170 km/h clothes might say
the very names Panamera Turbo S e-hybrid
Sport Turismo makes more noise than the
car itself especially since you start
always off in electric mode the range of
all electric drive is 50 kilometers but
then as long as the battery is fully
charged statistically speaking
you've probably reached your destination
often your place of work within that
range all statistics for the muslin
cloth can tell by the way it handles
that this car is no featherweight and
weighs over two tons even so the
performance it demonstrates makes up for
it absolute zenith with a total output
of 500 kilowatts this flagship of the
Panamera series can pounce from 0 to 100
km/h in 3.4 seconds just barely above
idling speed the 850 Newton metres of
torque grab onto the all-wheel drive and
the hard charging team of a twin
turbocharged 4 litre v8
an electric motor carries the 2.3 ton
hatchback over the road as if it were a
matchbox car fuel consumption is rated
at 3 litres per hundred kilometers
reality is another matter
other women here Klaus affirms that when
you step on the gas you're mobilizing
680 horsepower and that gets you moving
the electric motor and combustion engine
work together to produce a colossal
acceleration to supersonically
before you can even say Porsche Panamera
Turbo S e-hybrid sport Turismo the
speedometer is already reading 100 and
more
[Music]
I bought that house has a look at the
interior and judges everything to be of
the finest quality the monitor is
spacious with touch screen and slider
technology it's all he needs
[Applause]
the new sport Turismo is the first
Panamera to be fitted to seat three in
the back
[Applause]
but faucets flow sums up if you like it
sporty and environmentally friendly at
the same time the Panamera Turbo S
e-hybrid sport Turismo could be the
right choice but you'll have to fork out
some 190,000 euros at the local Porsches
either
[Music]
you